hello hello
can you hear it
audio input
this is live
okay can you guys hear me now
um
this isn't silent comedy i'm not doing
some marx brother [ __ ] is it choppy this
is the van
i can show you around
um
sound is good now yes
hans yes
okay so
you know ask me anything i just got back
from skankfest
uh
i had a good kill tony i think someone
said i bombed
people said i didn't i'm not gonna put
my glasses back on these are my eyes
and you're just gonna have to get used
to them
i'll go like this if this helps
um
i had a good skank fest
i ate a lot of raging cajun i went to
joel osteen's church
i um
did a lot of [ __ ]
you guys look more close than normal how
tired are you i'm actually not tired at
all i slept a lot
cooking some food right now that i have
to go check on soon
appreciate your hanzo in your center for
a center near excited i'm no excited i
have very small eyes
uh let me put up something white on the
second monitor
what's white
white i'm just going to google white
my keyboard's really loud
yeah this is good this is like a ring
light for me
so this things are good i'm opening up
for rogan uh favorite korean dish
probably purgogy
so sweet and the meat is chewable and
tasty in the sauce you can use to pour
on
your
[ __ ] whatever hello hello is the mic
loud now
smash the like audio is too quiet turn
off the output
um
sorry guys i'm figuring this all out
live
on youtube thank you for being here for
me i don't know how else to turn it up
let me know if this is a good how many
kisses did you get skank fat zero i
slept with kristi vera and she would not
kiss me even though i asked she got
really mad that i asked
uh have you ever been given mono from
one of women you have kissed on stage
not from one of the women that i've
kissed on stage but just from
the
hogs that i kiss on tinder no just
kidding i've never gotten mono i think
people overplay
diseases
uh are you in the van right now yes i'll
give you a little tour
um
oh my god
what a mess this is my van this is the
everything going on right now
whatever it's hard to move it around
this is the front
yeah look at that
is my fridge
is this on auto focus
yeah this is the van right now watch
your hygiene routine before you go off
on stage
my hygiene routine is i drink water so i
stop gagging
because
i've smoked so much weed that i start
gagging sometimes
my throat's really sensitive
you have a pic in the pc in the van holy
[ __ ] lmao i mean it's a mod it's a tv
that i can hook up my laptop too
yeah i can commit crimes in this this
tony carrots or hey tony's not a horse
that's very offensive to my boss
van life is pretty cool south georgia
usa in the house
let's see them deems vape
this live from kim's van are you
stealing your wi-fi i'm parked in front
of my friend's house riley gilmore he's
letting me stay here
um weed for life big fan
do you brush your teeth before kissing
the girls not really i just do whatever
i normally do and
i think that who i am as a person
deserves to be kissed because i think
everyone deserves to be kissed even if
you're not that attractive or if you're
not that good of a person i think you
deserve to be kissed because then you
might become a better person bluntzer
joins blunts
uh or yeah
yeah i'm stealing wi-fi it's not very
fast
do you like why do you like white women
so much i mean they're hot i mean
they're available it's i'm in america i
mean if i hated white women i'd be
having a very hard time
because
this is america after all
so i i love the women of the country
that i'm from that i'm in what have you
done already that's going to get you
cancelled in 2026.
oh a lot of stuff i've lived the life
i'm 32 i am
a bad boy i do a lot of bad things
um your wi-fi sucks what do you want me
to do i gotta open up the
door that kind of helps the wi-fi
there's the door slightly open now
maybe that'll improve the wifi
okay so
back to business
i uh
i'm not using my phone as a hotspot i'm
using my friend's wifi
i've got all the bars except one right
now so it's not too bad
um
i don't [ __ ] in the van if i can help it
i have i have
done it before and i know how to do it i
got a nice garbage can now with curved
lips so it's not so rigid
so that i can actually sit on it but i
use i used to have this um
other thing
i used to have this bucket which had
jagged edges so i bought a toilet seat
so i could sit on it and take a [ __ ] but
this toilet has curved lips so i can
just squat on it and take a [ __ ] in the
van if i have to
but i tried to not [ __ ] in the van it's
just
toxic waste it's poison
it's not very friendly
how did you know that you can wear vans
on your feet
i live in van a van on my feet
um
i got this sure microphone i got another
one coming tomorrow so i'm going to be
able to do podcasts with other people
this microphone is kind of low they say
i don't know what to do about that i've
turned it up as much as i can
it's kind of frustrating i don't know
why it's so low
it should be at this level but maybe i'm
whispering too much
hello hello
i'll just talk a little louder
so i went to skankfest i did
kill tony last monday and it went better
than the week before which hasn't come
out yet
um
how does your van smell i mean i think
it smells fine but christy vera thinks
it smells like food which she hates she
hates food because she's not a human
um
volume is good it's not a sprinter yes i
can stand up in it
it's got high roof
capabilities i built all these overhead
cabinets
i'm so proud of these overhead cabinets
that i built
um
yeah i mean
i just
kind of
used my sense of reality and
physics to sort of build myself
my own cabinets i don't think anyone on
the internet has ones so shitty
and cheap like this is just really thin
panel
board
and then some of the covers and
the hinges and all that
i'm just it's just
cool to make your own [ __ ] because then
you
put your own personality and how you see
the world into it and
i really like my uh [ __ ] overhead
cabinets
um
i love kimchi it's in the thing
chrissy vera is an insane person
question mark yes undoubtedly so very
nice person but very insane as well
and very interesting and very nice and
very
beautiful and charismatic
is your name hans or pingding
hello i am bing ding
sometimes i feel i find myself
battling my inner pengdang
i have to keep my inner pandang down and
no hans do not get all asian and asian
pride on people no one gives a [ __ ]
that your feelings are hurt because they
brought up being asian
um
i mean people are gonna bring up
whatever they can this is a doggy dog
society so if you're asian they're gonna
bring that up and if you're gonna get
butt hurt every time someone brings it
up
you're gonna be but hurt a lot
more like gay hurt
what is your opinion of
anarcho-syndicalism
um as much as i wish i was hasanabi i'm
not
anarcho-syndicalism
um seems like
very
a lot of small units of people doing
whatever they want on their own which is
nice
but i think like
overall we should be more united and
you know like use our power as a species
together instead of just going off on
our own but building something amazing
together
hopefully the wi-fi is better now
because there's
ambient noise coming in
from outside what's your favorite
breakfast i usually don't eat breakfast
i feel like my stomach is way too
topsy-turvy in the morning i let it
settle down and i do a little bit of
intermittent fasting where i completely
empty out my stomach so that there's
nothing in there so that it can just
settle and
reconfigure itself find out who it is
and what it wants from my life
and then
and then and then i eat what is your
favorite virtue signal probably that you
care
about a woman's safety
because if you get in on that level on
that base level then they're gonna be
like oh man i love
that you love my safety
um
that's so sweet or whatever and it's
like
obviously everyone is supposed to care
about each other's safety so it's like
such an obvious virtue signal
and it's like
you're basically just miming your basic
human emotions like no really i care
about you
i care about you are you gonna get home
safe
no really i can defend you and the idea
that you can defend someone else is
ridiculous when you can barely even
defend yourself
tell us about the federal reserve that's
just a joke i have in my girl talk joke
i say
i wish women will learn how to listen to
hans
why don't you want to hear about the
federal reserve
my friend's like you need to learn how
to talk to women i'm like maybe women
should learn how to listen to haunts why
don't you want to hear about the federal
reserve
federal reserve is like a private bank
that controls our money and like
hopefully they do good [ __ ] with it but
who knows their incentives or whatever
i'm actually not five seven i'm five
eleven and a half
i think with good posture i could be six
feet
are you korean yes
do you have a gun i'm not telling you
but
i'm also gonna buy again i might be
buying two i might be buying a gun to
have two guns or buy my first gun but i
don't really want to tell people if i
have a gun or not
um i feel like that is opsec okay i'm
having operational security
i do have
that i want to bring out for show and
tell
a little self-defense
against animals
it's called a spear you can buy one on
amazon for 50 bucks
just pop it open
oh man
now i can murder
many things
but i try not to use it
what is this what is this live stream um
yeah i love this thing this makes me
feel safe for um animals and unarmed
humans of course i'm in texas so it's
not very useful
in terms of uh
other humans but i have the gift of gab
i didn't have it yesterday but usually i
can diffuse situations with my
gentility and my
social social whatever
my social skills excuse me sir do you
really want to shoot me i'm actually a
quiet little boy and i've done nothing
wrong i love you can you love me so that
you don't kill someone and ruin your
life you [ __ ] idiot
killing someone is like a big deal
people get really mad if you kill
someone so hopefully i can
with my logic and wit
tell them how stupid they are
and that'll prevent them from killing me
um
i am
are you high no i'm completely sober
these are just my eyes i don't know what
you want me to do about it
but um yeah i can see clearly
like to me this looks normal
like these are
my eyes fully open
um
are you good at math yeah i'm pretty
good at math
i haven't done it in a while
it's rusty are you
good korean or south korean
are you implying
jeffrey epstein that north koreans are
the good koreans
who knows um
communism
i think that this chat has a very left
word bent which i'm happy with because
that's sort of my bend
um
joe rogan is very beautiful i like
hanging out with him he's like very
charismatic and i just like to bask in
his glory because he's like
the
the wizard of menlow park of
[ __ ] whatever
hello hello
of our modern time
um i think that it's funny that
uh yesterday i almost got in a fight
with someone
oh my god it's picking up so much
ambient noise why is this so quiet is
there something i can do this does this
thing break
supposed to be a share microphone oh
it's not really picking up
on the
whole thing
wait a minute
does this help hello oh
that seems like it helped
make some noise if that helped
has a one thousand dollar mic set up
yeah i mean i uh don't have to pay for
rent so
joe rogan pays me
does joe
joe not pay you enough for a good
internet
i mean how am i gonna get internet in
here
when am i gonna get on jre who knows
um so i actually did this thing
yesterday where i went up on stage
someone was like
uh john d'onofrio has a joke which i'll
ruin for the five listeners
um or the seven you need a clown lifter
for the sure mic i've seen that i don't
really know what it does
um
fargo north dakota i hear you i'll try
to get up there if you can get
all 17 of your buddies to pay 10 bucks i
can definitely go up there
uh all 17 people that live in your city
um
joe i wish joe adopted you i wish joe
gave me better internet uh so yesterday
i
went up after john i was hosting a mic
and john dinofrio went up and he said
there's a ten thousand dollar bounty to
report abortion
people he said i would have done it for
500.
what an idiot the government is way
overpaying and then i went up there and
it was like half the woman
he give it up for feminist john
dinoffrio half the women that are
getting half the people getting aborted
are women so he's defending women
and then i said uh
there's like three women in here [ __ ]
abortions abortions are for idiots
and then
some guy um
[Music]
was like are you serious when i sat down
he's like are you serious about that
you really support abortions or whatever
and uh i was like no dude i was just
kidding and i was like you really hate
abortions you really whatever and they
try to fight me they try to fight
everyone
outside the open mic and it kind of
distracted from the comedy happening
it's weird how comedy is not interesting
enough
the fighting is more interesting than
the actual
comedy
how long did it take you to get to
purple belt in taekwondo taekwondo
about
a year year and a half i don't know if
they have purple belt i know it's white
yellow
green
i don't even remember the taekwondo
belts
i mean it was good just to
flex be flexible and stuff
cool story
okay i'm sorry
at a comedy show let's get serious lol
wow hans is responsible for every
abortion at the yellow rose
yeah bro i'm just knocking these
strippers up they can't help it
when i'm around them
they get all wet
maybe i'll record this
and then put it up online because
it looks really choppy
like this is really smooth for me right
now
because i have a higher frame rate than
the live stream
um
any shows in houston i already went to
skankfest i don't have any plans i hope
to be there soon
has tony ever paid you to be a power
pitcher
to
have sex with him
for me to have sex with him with my
penis and his butthole no never
have you drove through when nachi
washington
probably that sounds familiar i think
that's like right
in the mountains
um so
i uh
i wrote a little bit today
hey
this is what i wrote
um
i feel like a mask salesman in texas
that's if i'm not selling anything it's
like no one wears masks here this is
probably the least
masked state
i think it's weird that
kyle rittenhouse is on trial right now
ooh
[Music]
juicy
watching him cry you know
it's like he was at a protest with a gun
he was protesting
and then he shot someone obviously if
you're at a protest
you understand the risks
and it's kind of scary to be there if
everyone has guns
and it's a
kind of
incendiary to go there with a gun
um
because they're mad that they're getting
shot and then you're like well i'll
shoot you again if you [ __ ] up
so it might rub people along wrong way
the long way
where can we see you do your sets in
austin tonight i don't have any shows
tomorrow i'm at flukerville with tywin i
should post that poster
although i might not do that because
tony hates it when i do these shitty
shows
uh what's your earliest memory you can
think of why is that you've asked that
twice now
uh the earliest memory i can think of is
probably
my
grandma holding me and i'm crying i'm a
little baby
she's like tapping my back
and then my mom comes up and i was like
[Music]
oh
ricky then she takes me and that's my
earliest memory but at this point it's a
memory of a memory
that's just something that i remember
um
and then other than that the earliest
memory i can think of is
i'm playing at a church camp we all went
on a retreat like about 40 miles 40
miles out of town and i was playing in
the field and i stepped on a yellow
jacket's nest and i got stung like 15 20
times so that's a memory why is tony
your daddy because he is comedically
more successful and further ahead and
then he's giving me
the graciousness of his
access
and
clout and helping me out in very many
ways and so he's my daddy
you know there's a lot of korean there's
a lot of comedy daddies out there and i
just happen to choose or i just happen
to have been chosen by one of the best
comedy daddies
in the world
uh comedy's a tough game and a lot of
people
way funnier than i don't have
as good of a daddy as tony does as tony
is so i'm very happy to suckle on his
teats
and
lie prone for him and have him finger my
butthole whenever he wants
it's just the name of the game you know
it's nerve-wracking being around someone
who's dick you would suck if he asked
but you know i think i have
enough self-discipline and self-worth to
not just
prostate myself at his feet
how much do you practice guitar not at
all i wish i could practice more
um i don't know if this stream would be
helped with the presence of a ukulele
but i have one
and
now i gotta play it because
i got the bug
hopefully it's in tune it's probably not
[Music]
something for tony it's a scale man
um i mean
i don't think simping is that bad i
think that we should actually be simping
a lot for everyone
and
since we live in a culture where
we only care about ourselves we don't
sip for anyone and then when we find one
person to simp onto we simp overly
we over
we overly simp
[Music]
but i would love to send for all of you
i want to simp
all this
i do have a gofundme and a patreon just
google it
oh my god people really hate this
all right
enough of that
i'm a goddamn comedian my skills lie in
wit and humor
william montgomery i he lives in i'm not
going to tell you where he lives but he
lives uh like 15 minutes away from me 20
minutes i want to do a podcast with him
when i get my other sure microphone it's
gonna happen
are you bo burnham now i wish i was as
talented unfortunately i can only mutter
logical statements into a microphone and
i don't have as much creativity hans are
you closeted homosexual
um yes
but that means i'm not because i just
came out so no
let's go my favorite korean defector
i love north korea
what do you guys want what do i have to
do to keep you as a listener i don't
know what to do
um
is joe normal no joe is not normal
joe is the most intense person [ __ ]
ever he's just
he's just like
laser focused in on the conversation
and he's just talking
um and like if you're not that focused
then you will get barreled over
and it's better to just listen to him
because he's he's like
he's like the most famous person and the
most interesting person in most
conversations that he's in so people
want him to talk a lot and it's not like
he's talking over people he's just like
talking
a lot because
he likes to do it and also that's what
is required in the moment so it's like
really beautiful to see
how he navigates the moment and how he
never overextends himself
emotionally or
isn't more vulnerable than he needs to
be
um he's a beautiful beautiful man
why has killed tony streamed a two weeks
before it premieres because they had a
pandemic
and that kind of [ __ ] everything up
and [ __ ] got crazy
um
[Music]
my eyes have nothing to do with drugs
okay
this is just my epicanthal folds
they just have heavy eyelids
it's hard to keep them up
but um
i
can get surgery to fix that one to ten
squid games uh squid games is actually
an allegory about the
like if you live in a society that's
just controlled by money you can make
people do anything you want so it's not
really a good basis for morality or a
culture we need to have something more
than just money
i would love to be on squid games season
two
uh hans king what's up zone zone
what's up dude if i get on kill twenty
first time ever will tony destroy me for
having a mustache
it seems like you're insecure about your
mustache
um
and i think that's funny because
you know a lot of people are insecure
about their body and a mustache is
purely optional so it's like a thing
that you can make fun of and it's not
that big a deal
um
[Music]
yeah i mean
people are always like are you worried
am i gonna be roasted i'm so worried
about going on kill tony am i a good
enough person it's like if you're a good
person and most of the people around you
agree that you're a good person then
you're probably a good person but if you
go around making a fool of yourself and
people are like wow this guy's
[ __ ] stupid a lot look at a stupid
mustache if everyone else is like that
tony will probably be like that too
because he's just working with what
everyone else is working with he's just
better at observing and better at making
you
realize how
sad or how how pathetic you are like
he's good at like pointing it out in a
funny way and roasting you
slay any v lately nope
completely unslaying for a while
uh who are the comedians that inspired
you
mitch hedberg taught me that jokes can
be
transcendent and simple you don't have
to
you know
like make it super complicated but
simple ideas can be
super transcendental
george carlin is great
have you ever met bobby lee i think i
might have seen him live at
whatever
in parlor but i don't think i've ever
talked to him
funny sorry
well that's kind of what's funny is that
sometimes he's not funny and it's funny
that he can just be unfunny on stage
uh my favorite game is starcraft 2.
um the red pepper zero go gold belly
through gold belly
yes please send me food
that'd be nice stephen wright is great
um
stephen wright or uh what's the same
[ __ ] steve martin is one of my
inspirations like he just
figured out
the meta of comedy and he's like making
fun of the audience and like doing
things where he knows what the
audience's reactions are gonna be
are you streaming from inside your van
yes doug stanhope is great when are you
coming to europe to tour as soon as i
have a lot of money
what is that photo next to the window
i don't know what you're talking about
uh this is just the outside
what rank are you in sc2 probably
diamond uh i wish i was master os master
league before
um platinum is a little too low for me
um but i really want to play again
i should play again
um 48 laws of dating advice for someone
ready to drop everything in their home
state and move to another advice i would
say
do it and
you know like have confidence in your
ability
to um go around and
play and have fun and
that you'll be able to withstand
whatever comes i mean this is 2021 we
have roads and homes and infrastructure
chances are you're going to be fine
um
it's not like you're going to have to
buy
or you know you're not going to have to
murder native americans and
hunt for your own food you should be
good
do you still do you think you will ever
get on rogan's podcast i mean the
precedence has been set with ali
makovsky
and
others i think maybe kim congdon has
been on it or maybe not
but ali makovsky has so if i can hang
out with joe
and make him like me enough maybe he'll
invite me to the biggest podcast in the
world but it's really not necessary i'm
just happy to open for him at this point
and get to hang out in the green room
it is an honor to soak in his energy in
person
and it's going to be something that i
can tell people in the future
that i used to
know joe rogan and used to be inside of
his inner sanctum
on certain days
um talking is fun what is the merch drop
and can we get a van sticker yeah i
should do that merch it's like such a
[ __ ] i gotta get everything figured
out and do everything
uh as a japanese what is your favorite
anime i'm not japanese so if i were to
become japanese my favorite anime would
probably have to be avatar the last
airbender
because i would secretly hate myself for
raping all those people in world war ii
and for
dooming pan-asian unity for the next two
centuries
with my hateful hateful
japanese
body
i don't really go in for anime i love
anime
anime is fun
i think it's great because you can
purely focus on storytelling you don't
have to worry about
you know the set
you don't have to worry about actors you
just [ __ ] write the story that you
want and then you can make it as good as
you want
i love stories and too much of acting or
real movies is like zooming in on the
actor's face and watching them try to
stand up for five minutes while an axe
murderer is behind them oh my god look
how good they are at struggling
with emotions
i'm a big fan of cars 3 myself what
crazy year it has been for you keep
working strong thank you so much it has
been a crazy year the beginning of 2021
i was in the desert
mount superstition mountain in
california
with my van
in the in the wilderness riding out the
fourth wave of coronavirus
um i just have a normal thing
so i don't know how much
that i should send people my address but
if you make a tempting offer i might
have to send you my address
so um yeah and then i was in the desert
for like three months and then i went to
yuma arizona to hang out with my friend
rebecca peterson
and we just hung out
she has a little casita she let me park
my van there and plug into electricity
user wi-fi and i did a lot of [ __ ] to my
van there i put in the overhead cabinets
put in a new battery
learned how to sling
um
[Music]
and
then from yuma after like a month or two
there i went to
[ __ ] texas
because i was like i've already been to
l.a
i haven't been to austin and plus joe
rogan and kill tony is there my favorite
two things in the world
so i went there and then i got to become
a regular on kill tony and started
opening up for rogan so
move to austin and your dreams will come
true
it has for me
i'm an austin success story i love this
city whenever i leave i want to come
back
this is such a beautiful city for me uh
there's mics every night there's comedy
shows there's
the biggest comedy shows in the world
happening right here
it's really truly a great great
experience to be here
um
i miss it whenever i'm away other cities
are not that good right now other cities
don't have the hope and the vitality
that this city has
and i always look forward to coming back
to austin texas
what does kill tony pay you
kill tony pays me in
recognition and love and
a couple hundred bucks every now and
then
and opening up for tony pays me well
opening up for rogan pays me well
it's i'm uh good on money i also have a
lot of unemployment money left over from
the pandemic and i have more money now
than i've ever had in my life
thanks mostly to the pandemic and to now
my new job
opening up for the biggest comedians in
the world so life's pretty good
financially and plus i
live in a van so i don't have to pay
rent so i have a lot of money saved up
so that way
things will continue to improve in my
life
what's good with paige a lot of page
questions paige and i
had a falling out and now we're not
talking to each other
i mean we are
we wish each other well and we went our
separate ways uh things didn't work out
with paige
um just like little
personality differences and like just in
general like where we are in our life
and just didn't work out
she's a very nice lady very beautiful
nice lady and i miss her and i hope
she's doing well
and
um
it's just like i'm maybe too sensitive
i'm a little bit of a [ __ ] and paige is
a
little tougher than i am so
i think that
it's a interesting gender role reversal
she's
uh hurt she
she's very she hurts my feelings more
than i hurt her so hopefully um but yeah
she's tougher than me and she's very
very uh very sexually attractive to me
um
how old are you i'm 32
would you ever pursue acting
yes i think acting is very easy to
pursue
i mean that's what joe rogan says turn
the page brother i'm trying to but you
guys keep asking about her jesus just
because i bring her up on the show every
chance i get doesn't mean that you can
associate me with her
no i she beats me she beats a and
connect four she's very good connect
four player
um disc golf courses i don't play disc
golf
i would love to you know sounds like fun
i'd rather play real golf
or basketball but i mean disc golf is
fun too if you get into it i could get
into anything
we're all you know blank slates and we
uh
are shaped by our environment
have you ever heard of a paw shop i've
had a similar thing some girls think man
or stone ll
yeah i mean
it's hard being an incel
people keep trying to make me whatever
are your parents proud i think so
how san antonio it's pretty good i'm in
austin though is that fan funny i
actually opened for that fan he's like
one of the first people i opened for
yeah he's a really good comedian
um he knows how to hold an audience and
he's a
very interesting person too what's your
favorite comedy club to play probably
the box
um creek is fun
um
what else is there
um
i don't know i like any small club
anything like uh tabula rasa brother
whatever
uh
the
original room and comedy story do you
have any children in your van
i mean
not alive children you sir are a
magician you make me laugh every episode
of kill tony thank you i hope that i can
keep that up you know i don't want to
just resort to kissing girls every
chance i get but you know it's a nice
perk
i've ever been gay uh no
that's gay
is there a podcast that you would like
to get on yeah every single top 10
podcast mark maron joe rogan
i'm already on kale tony uh
this american life true murder podcast
i like to be a guest not a story
and if i am i'd rather not be a victim
so i guess i'd have to be a perpetrator
how many more years till we get a hans
comedy special
comedy special i mean
i really want to make a good comedy
special and right now i'm nowhere close
to being ready for a comedy special
if i were to record a comedy special
i would want to
tour on the road from with my hour for
at least a year at least a year
um so
yeah that's not happening anytime soon
uh but if i can because like anyone can
do an hour but can you make it a good
hour and an hour that can stand the test
of time with the greats
um so it's it's just something that i
really want to get good i want to get a
good hour
i want to do the hour so many times that
i know every turn and twist of the hour
and then
and then i want to record it i don't
want to just barely do an hour
i want to have honed the hour for years
uh and then record it how much did the
van setup cost the van cost
twelve thousand dollars eleven thousand
nine hundred
and then i started living in it right
away so at that point the van setup cost
however much that is
and then slowly i started adding things
to it the the solar panels
you know it cost a lot i probably bet
like 10 000 more
but that's over a long period of time so
instead of paying rent i just make small
improvements to my van
um
who kills the hardest
you've seen samuel
in seattle gabriel rutledge in olympia
those are some old school people are not
old school but like some people that you
might not know who murder really hard
tony hinchcliffe murders really hard joe
rogan murders really hard
um
casey rocket murders really hard
who else
i think that
a lot of the new york comedians do
really well
brett raybould it's really funny
han's the swedish sherman sounds like a
real jerk
i mean don't forget the kim part the
south korean part kind of
levels out the
anger and the swiss engineering and
coolness has anyone seen this gf i don't
have a gf i'm single asians do need
sunscreen i get burned a lot
why do you mean in smash who do you mean
in smash
uh
samus
ness i do his upbeat move and i smash
people
i do i hit myself with that i hit them
with myself
um
do asians have to wear sunscreen yes
what kind of question is that that's
slightly racist
uh can you stop saying comedians murder
because we all know brennan chubb is the
king
straight murderers b
yeah i read the [ __ ] memes
do you asians have to wear sunscreen uh
yes
asians are not black even black people
have to wear sunscreen
we have very delicate skin
and plus we hate being tan
we like being pale as [ __ ] because that
shows that you're in the aristo
aristocratic
aristocracy
aristocracy
hans try to get tony to bring kill tony
to olympia
why would we go to olympia
i mean seattle's right there i mean
if we go to olympia we're gonna have to
go to [ __ ] sacramento too i guess
sacramento's sorry i don't mean a [ __ ]
on olympia in sacramento
um
hans isn't just
just isn't a draw
a draw
can you do a donald trump impression
listen
folks
folks it's huge
i i live in a huge van
it's huge
i'm not doing that again
do asians have to wear sunscreen yes
asians have to wear sunscreen if they
don't
then they get burned if they they're
fine with being burned they don't have
to wear sunscreen or if they get really
tan like there are some pictures of some
dark asians they look really dark
i'm not tony chan i haven't been
torturing and
trolling
william montgomery this whole time i'm
another asian person is joe rogan really
that short i mean he's not that short
but he is short how many girls have you
tapped since in austin probably like
five
maybe four
uh 20 year old and thinking about doing
van life any tips brother
uh do it now do it early and every
time every month you don't have to pay
rent is money in your pocket at least
you're buying something you have
an asset you have capital if you have a
van then it's nice because
you don't have to
you know [ __ ] with other people telling
you what to do and you're free
economically you have complete freedom
you don't have to
do anything you don't want to do except
live in a van
which isn't that great but
it's better than sacrificing your morals
and your
soul for a company just to live
this is better to make your own [ __ ] and
make something of your life
other than what other people want to
make it of you make your life
because they if you let other people
control your life they're just going to
make you work for their benefit for
their profit
and that's okay
it's okay in our society to make other
people work for you and waste your life
for your benefit but um that's not
really that fun for you
how high are you i'm very high i'm not
high at all i wish i was high maybe then
i could formulate a happy thought
um i'm not high
i wish i was i stopped smoking weed
because
it [ __ ] up my throat i have a very
sensitive throat how do you feel about
bitcoin i think let's start using it
let's start speculating on it and let's
actually do something with it like
[ __ ] finances or something does tony
control your life no tony doesn't
control my life although if he did i
wouldn't really mind i think that the
idea of autonomy and individualism is a
myth and
that
it's nice to be controlled by other
people because even if they do try to
control you they can't really control
you so
um
no tony doesn't control my life tony is
an american and he respects individual
rights and he respects freedom
uh yeah so tony doesn't control my life
i wish he did
can i rent a seat in your van to live in
mr wolfgang
you sound like a big german broad
i mean
big german fella
i don't think i want a sauerkraut in
here
comedy store
i love the comedy store
uh can you do a van tour video one day
sure
i mean this is so [ __ ]
slow that i don't think that i can do a
van tour right now but maybe if i have
better internet how do you feel about
the discipline you've practiced on the
road to success
honestly this discipline i have for
comedy hasn't been too hard to do i
write for an hour every day i go to open
mics and i do mics every day that's
really not that hard for me it comes
naturally and easily when i'm sitting
alone i'm like oh this is boring i
should write writing makes me feel like
i'm actually doing something and i don't
even get anything good out of writing
most of the time it's just an exercise
to get what's in my head out and then
once it's out i don't have to think
about it anymore or i can judge it for
what that thought is and be like oh i
don't want to think about this no more
and
physically see my thoughts
in real life and understand
what those thoughts are and then open
mics are a blast i hang out with friends
i get to do comedy i get to go up in a
bar and yell at people and tell them
what i'm thinking and i get to influence
a bar full of people with my emotions
and change their emotions it's just so
much fun and it's very easy to motivate
myself to do did you just wake up no i
did it
i've been up for a while now my hair
looks like this
uh my eyes are always like this
see the glasses help my eyes look a
little bigger but then i have to like
put something on my face
um
i uh
okay i think i have to go check my ribs
cooking i might come back i might do
this on instagram
i might try to figure out how to make it
not so choppy but thanks for coming in
and thanks for listening i hope to do it
again and hope that
we that you like me and that
maybe
you'll come back and that you know like
maybe you'll think that i'm not such a
bad guy
and maybe we can like hang out on stuff
okay